lisanna yamaha go is a doctoral
researcher in communications and
journalism since 2012 he has spent half
of his study time at his partner
university in belgium the free
university of brussels coming from
burkina faso it is an enormous
opportunity for him la condición ec
elevator key adamo / meadow dr hon
dupois lucia von cd2 career due to
minneota Shesha for non-eu students and
researchers the visa process is often
highly complex each country to its own
set of rules and hurdles to overcome
this agreement has been reached to
facilitate mobility a must for Europe we
need them and the demography of Europe
is pointing out that we need to attract
skilled people from outside the EU in
order to foster growth and prosperity
the new agreement will allow third
country students to obtain a visa more
easily and enjoy greater mobility in
Europe researchers will also be able to
bring over their families and stay for
up to nine months after the completion
of their placement giving them the time
to potentially find work in Europe the
text is set to be endorsed by a plenary
before the summer